deux mois sans pouvoir se rendre en
boutique cinquante cinq jours sans
réaliser le moindre shopping en magasin
après cette longue attente et bien que
le virus soit toujours fortement en
circulation certains français se sont ré
faire du shopping
quitte à devoir attendre plusieurs
dizaines de minutes
ces deux jeunes femmes vivent de
déconfinement comme une délivrance
alors c'est vrai que
pouvoir sortir par les magasins
fait beaucoup de bien nous savons que ça
nous a énormément manqué malgré les
commandes sur les sites nouveaux
scenarii livraison ils sont un peu
malgré la menace d'une deuxième vague de
contamination
cette mordue de shopping n'a qu'un
objectif pour cette journée renouveler
sa garde-robe coûte que coûte
alors on va aller chercher des habits
puisqu'on n'a rien
puis en plus on a pris des kilos pendant
le confinement du conte
on va refaire toute la garde-robe là
malgré l'absence de touristes de longues
files d'attentes se sont créés devant
les entrées de ces commerces de l'avenue
des champs-elysées à l'intérieur les
enseignes avaient anticipé leur
réouverture de plus plusieurs semaines
on a donc tout ce qui est beau affectant
lingettes desprès on a également des
éponges table dont on utilise plus de
pinceau là également des kits comme ce
site
donc pour le rouge à lèvres pour le
mascara
c'est un kit par client ce magasin de
cosmétiques a même été plus loin pour la
protection de ses clientes est de son
personnel
les produits ne peuvent être testés ou
même touché ce qui laisse perplexe
certaines clientes
à l'intérieur on veut pas toucher les
produits les cosmétiques on peut rien
faire c'est les vendeurs qui doivent
nous les données directement et doivent
ouvrir les tiroirs mais tout est
plastifié on peut on peut rien toucher
quoi les boutiques remettent petit à
petit le pied à l'étrier
une reprise en douceur qui ne doit pas
laisser de côté la vraie priorité la
santé